hi i'm fran krantz here are some simple  and effective hangover cures  exercise any kind of electrolyte heavy  drink especially the ones for infants  iced coffee when you're  hungover and you need to get some  immediate satisfaction and can't take  the time  with hot coffee calling your parents  everything's fine no my life's great  maybe  you'll believe it when the  conversation's over over the counter  medication coconut water  booze movies video games sunshine  getting outside sex  it's really hard when you're hungover  masturbation probably weird  pot let's be honest marijuana is going  to help with a hangover you know you  have to pick  drugs versus girls usually when i'm  hungover there's no one there to have  sex with well thanks guys i'm frank  crans and those are a few of my problems  ah hangover cures